everyone knows Arnold Schwarzenegger as
the world famous bodybuilder but did you
know he actually started his career with
a bricklaying company when Arnold first
got to La he had no money so he decided
to start a bricklaying company and he
employed all the other bodybuilders from
the gym but there was one problem no one
wanted big hulking bodybuilders to lay
bricks in La so what did Arnold do he
decided to create a special European
bricklaying company because Americans
were obsessed with Europeans and he
convinced people that he and the other
bodybuilders had been trained on top of
a mountain by monks on how to lay bricks
perfectly business started to boom and
all of a sudden Revenue flooded in and
then Arnold was able to take the profit
from his new European bricklaying
company and use it to buy real estate
and begin investing Arnold
Schwarzenegger today is known as an
actor the governor and a bodybuilder but
he also was a hell of a businessman